let's talk about the 25th of june
oh yeah
let's talk about
lavon
sigunishvili
the georgian hulk
yeah uh question number one
is it possible to beat him he is widely
acknowledged as uh
the most powerful person
in arm wrestling today
is he
beatable and it's so how everybody's
beatable everybody's beatable lavon is
incredible he's uh he is
what
this
modern peak of arm wrestling represents
so for people who are just listening we
we also have an overlay of a video
of levon going against vitali leden
um another top three person in the world
perhaps yeah in arm wrestling and the uh
lavon's the guy on the right just big
i love it and the the aggression
uh i mean actually sort of underneath it
all is it seems to be a teddy bear but
when he turns it on yeah it's uh
it's raw power he's the full package
lavonne is uh he represents the pinnacle
um there's dennis in the background
he's like i want to be back in there
yeah
levon has a lot of bases covered uh he's
i mean he's curling 300 pounds with one
arm i mean the strength that he shows
for arm wrestling
is
is is so far ahead of the field is very
very strong
um
[Music]
but
it's absolutely possible it's absolutely
possible the one thing that i'm
confident about well i'd say there's two
things
the two things i'm confident about is
that i have more experience than he does
and
experience counts for a lot
the other thing is
my ability to
breathe and recover so
if ever
there's an opportunity for the tide to
turn
that's i think where he'll never get it
back so i think if i can somehow find a
hole in his game
then uh yeah
so you you want to hold off the initial
like assault of power
and that and then
wear them out
and to find the hole and then
it's how much of that is mental how much
of it is just the physical ability to do
for your muscles to have the endurance
to hold off
i like to
make the sport bigger
and a lot of things that
most arm wrestlers
believe the sport is
i always try and push those boundaries
so
there is definitely a mental aspect to
it when you're faced with something that
you've never seen before
that's when things like experience
comes in he can become surprised
where
what's a surprise for him is routine for
me
so my adjustments will be more precise
more accurate
um
yeah that's how i get in
that's how i get in yeah i play i play a
dirty game
you know so some of it uh how important
is confidence in the whole
in the progression of the match
is there
ups and downs of confidence like holy
[ __ ] i actually have a chance to win
this
holy [ __ ] i'm winning this you're done
there's some of my favorite moments i
don't know if those are fake or not in
terms of your expressions if it fake it
until you make it but whenever you shake
your head or whatever it you make it
apparent that
you believe
the match is finished
and i wonder if that gets in the head of
the other person
when you start to actually
uh so i'm sure you're doing things in
like precise detailed things with your
hands to also indicate that you believe
they're finished but you're facially
just you see this yeah
quit
oh that's right because it's 15 yes
so that's ultimately what the battle is
about it's like it's you're done it's
you might as well give up
commitment is so important in anything
that you do right like
i always
kind of try and bring things to
a level of commitment that's uncommon i
i think that that's a lot of reasons why
i do well
it's because i just get so committed in
the whole process
and
by the time that i actually show up to
fight
i sometimes just wish that they would
kill me you know i wish that they would
because that's what that's how far i
want to go like people talk about like
how committed are you to the match like
if you're committed to the match and you
lose you should be hurt like that's i'm
often unhappy
when i lose a match
and i don't have an injury i'm like damn
i'm like what the [ __ ] like i shoulda
like i feel i feel like i didn't commit
you know
uh i don't know if you know dan gable is
the wrestler he oh yeah he was don uh he
has on the podcast yeah yeah yeah uh
he he talked about his whole career he
dreamed of
working so hard that he gets
he can't get off the mat right by
himself
and he was always dis he's disappointed
ultimately at the end of his career
because he was always able to get off
the mat on his own accord so he wants to
yeah leave it all
on the mat just from exhaustion
see that that's what commitment looks
like yeah what what is this process what
is this climb for
probably the toughest match of your
career
i would say the most epic match in in
arm wrestling
history i mean it's really building up
you are the you said north america
that's a
i mean i think
uh
by a council of men you're one of the
greatest arm wrestlers ever he is one of
the scariest wrestlers ever
and so this match uh by the way where is
it happening it'll be in dubai in dubai
yeah june so what does the climb look
like
the climb for me um what i have to
change in my life always
people talk about being a professional
i've always loved the sport i've i've
loved it like crazy
but to me
the path is about
simplicity
and removal of distractions
um
i do better and better
the more i get rid of everything
nothing else um
so that my life is just
the goal just the target and everything
else is off the table and that's that's
where i need to get to
um where there's nothing there's nothing
between me and him and every single day
you're putting in the volume every day
all day now you said you worked out so
you yesterday you did hundreds of arm
wrestling matches and then today you
said in the morning you still worked out
so what was that work out so you're
mixing up stuff where you're doing
weights also uh this morning you know
i try to really focus on what's
administratively easy
uh that's a big part of it for me is
everything i do
so i just travel with bands
yeah i got bands with me
and it's rehabilitative in nature so
i'm really focusing on blood flow
uh feeling good doing proper movements
but yeah just a band workout in the
hotel what does a band workout look like
so are you doing the the arm wrestling
movement are you oh
see what you did there what's that
yeah it's you that you want to bring him
in now
up
oh the up link up up up into your center
right yeah you think what can you
control out here
no you bring everything close
you won't ever just that's it don't
worry about pinning painting happens
once it's close to you yeah yeah the
pinning is
people always think about pinning you
don't think about pinning how much of
the body is a part of this too like the
uh the core
the torso because it feels like there's
that almost like a mike tyson punch
power right yep does it come from the
hips too and the
the legs
it just gives you the body the whole
body it's definitely the whole body like
everything is working
uh you're connected to the table at
times as far as your base sometimes your
base is your feet
but a lot of times you can base off the
table so
so you can base off your hips but i'll
tell you
no arm wrestler cares about doing squats
no arm wrestlers doing planks yeah okay
it's all about the forearm and the
actions of the hand yeah that's always
the limiting factor
you look at a guy like oleg zok okay do
you know this guy oleg zach
marvelous he's a he's that total hellboy
he's my inspiration to what i call
pumpkin training
but um what's pumpkin training uh
probably we'll get into that but i only
train my right arm that's it
yeah with homework
but
back to full body
it is full body my my good friend matt
mask
when he arm wrestled me he actually blew
his internal abductor in his in his leg
so yeah people walk away from tournament
their calves can be sore sometimes
you know it happens but
no oh there he is right there yeah oh
like he's he is a real life hell boy
he's like he's like 170 pounds there
look at his arm look at his hair
crazy yeah yeah he's totally crazy
that's you doing left right there so
that's by the way lavon you're going
right yeah
yeah
so can you say more about the the mental
side are you visualizing what it takes
to beat him are you trying to get in his
head um all of these things
so do you think it's possible to get in
his head
there's definitely strategies that you
can do depending on who it is you're
facing
it's very good to know who it is you're
fighting and choose the correct strategy
mentally
but
i
always follow a process
when it comes to my mental preparation
when i'm far away from an event
i just always
build up my opponent
build them i build them i respect them
to a point where i almost start to fear
them and start to believe that they'll
beat me
and this is a very vital part of my
preparation and that's where i am right
now with lavon i don't i just build them
up build them up into this thing that
scares me
and it forces me to be responsible you
know
because i don't want to lose you know i
want to win uh
so the greater my opponent the greater i
can build their worth and my mind
the more motivation it gives me
um
then there comes a point
when uh when it changes
and
then i start to degrade them
and
yeah that's when it normally starts to
get fun
and
normally by the time i face them
uh i just try and completely dominate
from every interaction from start to
finish
uh
yeah
when uh in the actual
moment of the match like in in the
moments leading up to it what's the
feeling
is it uh
fear is it confidence
anxiety what what's going through your
mind
i love to fight i love it uh love i
always have i um
there's
there's every day
um where you have you know the
distractions of life
and then there's really living in the
moment right it's whatever you love to
do and that's when you can you know
really be free
uh i i'm free when i'm fighting
right so you put me in that good fight
and i just love it i don't think about
the past i don't think about the future
i just think about killing that dude in
front of me and i enjoy that
and just being intensely in the moment
just that's it just right there just
fighting as hard as i can do you study
the opponent like do you have you for
this particular match
do you study videos of lavon i've seen
everything
i've read everything
i get opinions from other people
i watch
very closely yeah what do you make of
his evolution so so he's
he's grown in size
but also you've talked about his um
you know evolution technically as well
lynn studying him
since we're in the uh build your
opponent to be
terrifying stage uh what uh what makes
him great
he's very impressive the the greatest
thing about him is is his strength
that's the thing that sets him apart
from everyone
his strength
specialized strength
exact strength for arm wrestling
i believe it's unmatched can we just uh
linger on that
word strength what does strength mean
what does it feel like are we talking
about
um
bicep
like shoulder are we talking about like
whatever control right the wrist yeah is
it the
where what how does strength manifest
you know like when i touch your hand
when we grab arms i feel like
[ __ ] that
there's control what is that feeling
where does that come from we're in arm
wrestling when you're at the top of the
world where does that come from so
it's chains there's chains of strength
and in arm wrestling this is like
technical strength okay and we use these
technical chains to fight each other
the
the change that i'll talk about is
so you'll talk remember how we talked
about the post this upwards drive this
ability to close this angle
this is a chain
it can be used it's it's a technical
attack it's also an attack that can be
built with with training just the
ability to just drive upwards
uh there's a chain where you cup right
cup your wrist and cup your wrist in the
in the anchor and the chain brings you
right to your heart right to your center
right this chain and this can be done at
any time
uh there's a pronation chain and that's
that's to turn your thumb over right
turn your thumb over and you attack the
person's cupping chain and there's a
huge number of muscles involved in each
other's chains and that's why i say it's
a chain right but they're movements
and these movements
you can develop in the gym or through
practice so you don't mean so it's easy
to sort of interpret strength to mean
the the how much you curl essentially
yeah but you mean the chain it's all
right and that's like i mean people talk
is a bicep i mean yes there's bicep for
sure involved but i i'll always be
inaccurate if i try and tell you like
what muscles are the so i prefer to
explain it in a movement
and then everything that's involved to
do that movement
right
yeah and levon's movements for arm
wrestling
are incredibly impressive
what do you attribute to how much of
that is genetics how much of it is
some
training thing he's doing
i think that
lavon is very special in terms of
his genetics like not everybody can be
lavon
you know yeah there's there's not many
lavons out there
um
but
what i've encountered in the bias that i
always see like when people talk about
people like lavonne
they discount the other side so very
quickly
and the thing is lavon rarely has to
show it on the other side because he's
so far ahead you talk about the
technical application the sport
he so rarely needs to show it
but he's clearly incredible if you watch
his progression he came up
having very difficult technical
struggles to overcome georgia is a great
country for arm wrestling like there's
this guy gennady click vina who no one
would ever say is not technical
and
you know
it took him years to defeat him
to a point where now it's not it's not
even a discussion
you talk about the progression they had
a lot of battles together over the years
yeah it's fascinating to see the tides
turn oh yeah and once they've turned
it's like
completely completely different level
yeah i mean he's got he's got strength
he's got technique
some people
will argue that his technique is flawed
at times they've shown matches where he
hasn't shown the best technique but he's
still one
and i think sometimes he just plays with
people you know like uh there's a famous
match that he had with uh
uh they call him the bruce lee of arm
wrestling a guy called anger by of uh
court of galilean he's they had a match
in the top eight
great match critic ali is like 220 pound
guy from kazakhstan uh
brilliant technician but power wise you
know not in the same world
and kurdigali
did well even though he lost six nothing
he still did well
uh but in my opinion
lavonne didn't care lavon was like
grabbing him low and just like whatever
like
i will show him things that he's not
seen before i will
um
he hasn't competed often in this rule
set which will be a challenge for him
but uh
yeah what can i say like lavon he's he's
everest
yeah yeah
yeah you are seen by
basically everybody is the big big
underdog but you also even even in the
eastern even uh i mean i talk to
russians a lot
they're you uh you know that moment in
rocky when they start cheering for rocky
yeah yeah
you're kind of the they they love you
they want you to win and just you know
it's not even um
just the battle itself is inspiring and
it's it's it's like the culmination in
your career because
it's you know you're at the top for a
long time but it's like it's almost
like it should be over for you but no
you're returning it's it is like this
big
moment yeah the big climb i will be the
pointy end of the spear for north
america
you